if anybody's in Seattle and bar
beer-pong in North Dakota but you'll
find this month's mania Stanny deep in
the heart of Texas
considering my Brown Eric garner all the
other cases it seems like bad timing to
say the least well there's no question
that the timing is a little tone deaf
you know I looked at this legislation
when it came to me from the police
officers and I thought this is a
reasonable request Texas state Rep Jason
Villalba crafted a bill that's been
called one of the most anti Liberty anti
transparency anti-free speech big
government police state promoting pieces
of legislation I've ever read and that's
from a fellow Republican lawmaker and
you know maybe it's not quite right to
say via the crafted the bill since you
know it was written by police
organizations the so-called cop watcher
bill would make it illegal to shoot
video within 25 feet of officers we got
a bunch of people fighting with sticks
and weapons you are video having
description stop talking please
you are videotaping this crime scene but
thanks the exception carved out for news
media you could sidestep the regulation
as long as you have you know say an FCC
license what about bloggers and citizen
journalists
well the Alba says we just don't know
what their intentions are some are
intending to interfere because how could
an officer perform his duties with
someone standing you know 20 feet away
holding an iPhone when we had
significant death threats in the last
week my family became uncomfortable with
the Alba received an awful lot of
blowback and in response who said he'd
rewrite the bill or maybe ask the cops
who wrote it the first time I rewrite it
in order to reduce the distance to 15
feet and make it apply to everyone
including journalists also Villalba
wants all his haters to know that his
daughter loves french toast and snuggles
just go away I don't care where you go
go away
fallin ended a month on Twitter submit
your nanny nominees just like Lucas
Padilla who found this month's winner
way to go Lucas and check back next
month for more examples of busybodies
running your own business